jetzt kommen wir zu einer mord serie die
norddeutschland in angst und schrecken
versetzt hat und die der göhrde
eigentlich eine wunderschöne weit region
im nordosten niedersachsens den
schauerlichen namen toten wald einbringt
im sommer 89 werden hier innerhalb
weniger wochen zwei paare erschossen und
dann noch eine frau verschleppt der
mutmaßliche täter kurt werner wittmann
ein friedhofsgärtner genannt die blonde
bestie und wahrscheinlich hatte dieser
mörder ein komplizen und genau dieser
mann wird jetzt von der polizei gejagt
lena sander mit neuen exklusiven
recherchen
das ehepaar ursula und peter reinhold
aufgrund der spuren vermutlich
erschossen oder erwürgt
ingrid warmbier und bernd michael
pöpping sie wird erschlagen er mit einem
kleinkaliber gewehr erschossen
zwei doppel morde in der göhrde einem
waldgebiet bei lüneburg erschüttern im
sommer 1989 die menschen in
norddeutschland
ganz in der nähe verschwindet kurz
danach auch birgit meyer die sich jahre
später herausstellt wird sie entführt
geschossen verscharrt was im sommer 89
noch niemand weiß es war kurt werner
wittmann und indizien deuten an dass er
auch die beiden paare getötet hat und
vielleicht noch viele andere menschen in
ganz deutschland
seit mehr als 30 jahren kommen immer
neue details ans licht die wichtigste
frage hatte wich man einen mittäter der
immer noch frei herum läuft es ist der
wohl spektakulärste fall deutschlands
jeder mensch der den verbrechen begeht
muss auch bestraft werden
[Musik]
ich denke einfach mal
dass es gerechtfertigt ist wenn wir den
film
der seine strafe bekommt
zwei doppel morde in der göhrde und der
fall birgit meyer
lange jahre waren die ereignisse aus dem
sommer 89 für die ermittler ein großes
mysterium
der sommer 89 war ein
sommer der uns in vielfältige hatten
kommunistischer weise beschäftigt hat
mit fällen die wir so alles gesehen
haben
[Applaus]
und ich weiß dass sehr viele kollegen
aus der polizei gerade die die haben uns
an der sonderkommission waren auch bis
an die grenzen der belastbarkeit
gearbeitet haben um das zu klären
bild reporterin lena zander
rekonstruiert für achtung fahndung diese
spektakuläre mord serie ist es möglich
dass ein überführter täter noch für
zahlreiche weitere morde in ganz
deutschland verantwortlich ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im sommer 89 sind die gürtel morde und
das verschwinden von birgit meyer die
top themen in den redaktionen schnell
machen die ersten fälle deutschlandweit
schlagzeilen auch die bild reporter
berichten vom ersten tag an
unheimlicher weit mörder schon zwei tote
paare in der romantischen görder
kripo so sieht der gerte mörder aus
vermisste birgit meyer polizei ermittelt
wieder
für achtung fahndung geht reporterin
lena zander jetzt erneut auf spurensuche
in die gebäude das ist ein riesengroßer
wahnsinnig komplexer fall wir haben fünf
mordopfer zwei doppel morde und eine
frau die fast 30 jahre lang fünf gewesen
ist es gibt so viele wenden so viele
entwicklungen auch wie man so auch nicht
vorher erahnen konnte bild reporterin
nina zander trifft die tochter von
birgit meyer als ihre mutter von einem
auf den anderen tag verschwindet ist sie
20 jahre alt heute möchte sie nicht
erkannt werden die vergangenheit
eigentlich hinter sich lassen doch sie
kann nicht abschließen das schicksal
ihrer mutter die jahrzehntelange
ungewissheit quält die 53 jährige bis
heute
der eigenen mutter passiert ist das hat
das gemacht
mein ganzes leben kaputt
mein ganzes leben zerstört man lebte von
vermutungen spekulation
wusste nicht wann das aufhört und mich
hat es traumatisiert bis zum heutigen
tag
die göhrde ein staatsforst circa 60
kilometer südöstlich von hamburg es ist
sonntag der 21 mai 1989 ursula und peter
reinhold aus hamburg fahren in das bei
ausflüglern beliebte waldgebiet sie
wollen einen der ersten warmen
sommertage genießen was dann geschieht
ist bis heute unklar am 12 juli 1989
sieben wochen später entdecken während
sammler die verwesten leichnam des
ehepaars
[Applaus]
unglaublich während die polizei noch den
tatort sichert geschieht am selben tag
nur 800 meter entfernt ein weiterer
doppelmord die opfer die 46 jährige
ingrid verbier ausnützen und der 43
jahre alte bernd michael pöpping aus
hannover
kommt jetzt hier auf einer anhörung dann
geht das gleich einmal runter eine senke
das ist der von trott gewesen
nach der rechten hand voll zweigen aber
dass das zweite paar ist dann hier
aufgefunden worden da wo es heller wird
das wird der platz gewesen war
kriminalhauptkommissar thilo speicher
ist seit 2017 mit dem ermittlungskomplex
der göhrde wurde beschäftigt die taten
erschüttern damals das land die
bevölkerung ist beunruhigt
die göhrde morde sind herausragend
einfach faktisch weil vier
tötungsdelikte in sehr kurzer zeit
aufeinander folgend stattgefunden haben
die nach heutigem kenntnisstand einfach
auch einen tatzusammenhang darstellen
was damals niemand weiß auch das
verschwinden der unternehmergattin
birgit meyer nur wenige wochen später
hängt mit den göhrde morden zusammen in
der nacht vom 14 auf den 15 august 89
verschwindet birgit meyer spurlos die 41
jährige lebte von ihrem mann getrennt
alleine im gemeinsamen haus in
brietlingen nahe lüneburg ihre damals
20-jährige tochter erinnert sich
hatte am 14
889 mein letztes telefonat mit meiner
mama wir wollen noch mal telefonieren
sie wollte das war ein montag sie wollte
am dienstag sich für ihr neues haus
möbel kaufen
als sie am nächsten tag anruft geht
niemand ans telefon
als sie zum haus ihrer mutter fährt
steht die terrassentür auf auch sonst
ist einiges mehr für dich geldkassette
die offenbar im schlafzimmer mit guten
aschenbecher im badezimmer mit mit
fremder zigarettenmarke und im
schlafzimmer noch 26
was ist an diesem tag im haus von birgit
meyer geschehen wohin ist die 41 jährige
verschwunden aus heutiger sicht gehen
die ermittler davon aus dass birgit
meyer an diesem tag möglicherweise von
zwei tätern verschleppt wurde das
begründete sich im wesentlichen daraus
dass zum beispiel bei der bei der
entführung der frau meier ein fahrzeug
mit laufendem motor vor der wohnung
gesehen worden ist was ein
tatzusammenhang gehabt haben könnte
woraus wir geschlossen haben das
möglicherweise die einführung durch
einen täter und das fahrzeug von einem
anderen täter gefahren und sein kunde
im fall neuer glaubt die polizei
zunächst an ein freiwilliges
verschwinden aus privaten gründen als
nach zwei wochen meyers ausweis gefunden
wird werden die ermittlungen
intensiviert
einen zusammenhang zu den vier morden in
der nahegelegenen göhrde sieht man nicht
die göhrde morde haben bei den
ermittlungsbehörden dagegen oberste
priorität bereits nach dem ersten doppel
markt bildet die polizei niedersachsen
eine 40 köpfige sonderkommission
diese legt im laufe der jahre mehr als
1900 spurenakten an befragt und
überprüft fast 10.000 menschen
einer von ihnen ist kurt werner wittmann
er lebt in lüneburg und hat eine dicke
akte kommt in haft denn schon als
jugendlicher hat er polizisten mit einer
kleinkaliber waffe bedroht
frauen vergewaltigt und gewürgt
stand im verdacht mit einem
kleinkalibergewehr eine frau hinterrücks
erschossen zu haben
auch war der damalige friedhofsgärtner
an den tag tagen der beiden doppel morde
nicht bei der arbeit
damals als beamter im einsatz der
spätere lüneburger polizeipräsident
robert kruse
die sonderkommission hat uns damals
beauftragt haben wie ich mal zu
absolvieren
vom ablauf her ist es so gewesen dass
dort keine wahl antrat erkenntnisse
durch unser land werden kunden die wir
der sonderkommission hatten zu liefern
kann zu diesem zeitpunkt hatte die
polizei anhand von zeugenaussagen
bereits ein phantombild des
vermeintlichen täters erstellt weil kurt
werner wittmann meist eine brille trug
was nicht zum phantombild passte
verfolgten die spur aber nicht weiter
währenddessen im fall birgit meyer auch
hier geht die polizei mittlerweile von
einem verbrechen aus und
schaltet sich wolfgang sielaff rey er
ist kredit meyers bruder und damaliger
leiter des landeskriminalamtes hamburg
er macht die ermittelnden beamten in
lüneburg immer wieder auf offene fragen
und widersprüche im fall seiner
vermissten schwester aufmerksam ein mann
drängt sich seiner meinung nach auch im
fall der 41-jährigen als tatverdächtiger
auf
kurt werner wittmann denn erkannte
birgit meyer hatte kontakt zu mir auch
kurz vor ihrem verschwinden
vier jahre später 1993 wird wichmann zum
beschuldigten im fall meyer als die
beamten ihn zu hause aufsuchen ist er
nicht da sie rufen ihn auf der arbeit an
wichmann flüchtet im fall von kurt
werden sich mann der als verdächtiger
galt wurde er gewarnt die polizei hat
damit ihre chance verspielt das wichmann
zu hause war wichmann flüchtet nach
süddeutschland am 15 april 1993 wird er
bei heilbronn verhaftet als er in einen
verkehrsunfall verwickelt ist im
fahrzeug findet die polizei waffen
zehn tage nach seiner verhaftung erhängt
sich kurt werner wittmann im gefängnis
die ermittlungen werden eingestellt
es gab zum damaligen es hat ja keinen
hinweis dass er tatsächlich der täter
dieser dieser doppelmörder oder aber
auch da in führung gewesen dass damit es
gab nur abschiedsbriefe von ihm die
darauf hindeuteten dass er irgendetwas
zu verbergen hatte aber konkret auf die
tat hatten wir noch keine weiteren
hinweise noch keine beweisführung und
nach dem gesetz wird gegen tote nicht
weiter ermittelt die akte wichmann wird
2008 geschlossen
doch in abschiedsbriefen aus dem
gefängnis an seine familie
deutet man an dass er auf seinem
grundstück in adendorf etwas vergraben
hat er sorgt sich um ein tulpenbaum
chens und die reinigung der dachrinnen
sind es versteckte hinweise an einen
mittäter sollen spuren vernichtet werden
die briefe enden mit bitte denkt nicht
nur an meine schlichten sein gott sei
mir gnädig
fragen bleiben offen hat wichmann birgit
meyer wirklich getötet ob es mittäter
und war er womöglich auch in die göhrde
morde verwickelt
meyer verschwindet im sommer 89 die
göhrde morde passieren nur 35 kilometer
entfernt im selben sommer wir haben uns
dann nachdem ich hier auch präsident des
polizeidirektion geworden bin noch mal
dieser fälle angenommen und in
zusammenhang mit denen damals
vorliegenden aspekten haben wir gesagt
wir werden jetzt haben wir sehr sehr
gründlich zunächst mal den führungs fall
meyer auf arbeiten in dem wir noch mal
alle spuren und tatsächlich unmittelbar
ansehen und noch einmal an der
neubewertung unterziehen kann im zuge
dieser neubewertung im jahr 2016 stoßen
die ermittler auch auf blut bespritzte
handschellen die bereits 1993 im hause
von kurt werner wittmann sichergestellt
wurden nach einer dna untersuchung steht
schnell fest dass blut ist von birgit
meyer sie war also in der gewalt von
kurt werner wittmann doch birgit meyer
bleibt verschwunden ihrem bruder
wolfgang sielaff dem damaligen leiter
des landeskriminalamtes hamburg lässt
das keine ruhe als er 2003 in rente geht
rollt auch er den fall neu auf
zusammen mit alten weggefährten bildet
er eine private ermittler gruppe mit
dabei unter anderem der hamburger star
anwalt gerhard strate mit erlaubnis der
neuen besitzer durchsuchen sie akribisch
das ehemalige anwesen von kurt werner
wigmann unter anderem noch einmal das
sogenannte geheime zimmer das bereits
bei den ermittlungen 93 entdeckt wurde
damals waren auch verschiedene
gegenstände die dort sich gefunden
hatten also fessel werkzeuge
beispielsweise also
gerätschaften die geeignet wären
menschen andere menschen zu reinigen
also dieses geheimnis mehr war schon
tatsächlich auch so
dass man wirklich mit schaudern daran
dachte was wir wohl alles passiert sein
mag in der garage von wichmanns hausfeld
den privaten ermittlern eine
ungewöhnlich niedrige montagegrube auf
die eigentlich zum reparieren von autos
die gemeinsam mit einer
rechtsmedizinerin beginnen sie den beton
auf zu meißeln und zu graben anfänglich
ohne ergebnis bis sie durch zufall auf
einen hohlraum stoßen
diese stelle haben wir dann geöffnet und
ganz plötzlich hitze an knochen
und jetzt hoch und sagte das ist ein
mittelfußknochen
und sie meinte natürlich damit einen
mittelfußknochen eines menschen wie sich
herausstellt handelt es sich bei den
knochen um die sterblichen überreste von
birkenmeier eine spätere obduktion
ergibt dass sie mit einem kopfschuss
würde einerseits war es schon irgendwo
eine erleichterung gewissheit zu haben
gleichzeitig oder oder eine millisekunde
später hat man aber auch
war dieses dieses finale dieses
endgültige auch trotzdem schwer
auszuhalten für mich aber man hätte
einfach gerne andere antwort gehabt wenn
man ehrlich ist der fall mauer ist
gemixt doch was ist mit den morden an
ursula und peter reinhold sowie ingrid
warmbier und bernd michael kamping in
der nahegelegenen gerd im dezember 2017
gibt die lüneburger polizei bekannt dass
man auch für die göhrde morde als
dringend tatverdächtig geht weil unter
anderem in seinem haus tv mitschnitte
und zeitungsartikel über die göhrde
morde gefunden werden untersuchen die
ermittler nochmals die fahrzeuge der
opfer und finden darin wichmanns dna
unter beide fahrzeuge nach den taten
weit entfernt von den tatorten
abgestellt wurden wichmann aber seinen
eigenen wagen benutzt haben muss um in
die gänge zu kommen geht man davon aus
dass er einen komplizen hatte
dieser soll aus dem persönlichen umfeld
wichmann stammen mehr gibt die polizei
aus ermittlungstaktischen gründen nicht
erkannt wir führen einen verdächtigen in
diesem strafverfahren einen
beschuldigten das heißt es gibt eben
diese indizienkette die diesen anfangs
tatverdacht begründet es gab keine
haftgründe die man begründen konnte so
ist diese person am gleichen tage noch
wieder auf freien fuß gesetzt wurden
beweise zu finden durchsuchen 2018
ermittler darum erneut zwei wochen lang
das anwesen wichmanns stellen zahlreiche
fundstücke und beweismittel sicher
insgesamt rund 400 gegenstände die heute
in der asservatenkammer der
polizeidirektion lüneburg lagern viele
mit dna-spuren
zudem wird im herbst 2008 10 ein koffer
gefunden der jahrelang auf einem
dachboden in einem lüneburger
industriegebiet gelegen hat inhalt
schusswaffen und munition und ein
1976 ausgestellter führerschein von kurt
werner wittmann
doch neue beweise die einen mittäter
belasten oder den verdacht erhärten dass
wichmann auch die beiden doppel morde in
der gehörte begangen hat ergeben sich
daraus nicht
wir können auch nicht ausschließen ob
diese dinge im zusammenhang mit einer
anderen straftat stehen
zum beispiel einem anderen ort und für
uns ist dann die aufgabe zu prüfen gibt
es verbindungen zu anderen straftaten
oder gibt es verbindungen zu anderen
opfern und zu klären wo kommen diese
gegen schon mittlerweile vermutet die
polizei dass beckmann und ein möglicher
mittäter für weitere morde in ganz
deutschland verantwortlich sind alle
gegenstände werden fotografiert
katalogisiert und deutschlandweit mit
offenen fällen abgeglichen rund 200
taten werden mit wichmann in verbindung
gebracht und geprüft morde und
vergewaltigungen
doch anfang 2020 gibt die polizei
lüneburg bekannt dass sich keine
hinweise zu weiteren taten unter den
gegenständen ergeben habe
damit werden auch die doppel morde in
der göhrde zum cold case
[Musik]
speziell der aengevelt tatzeitraum das
ist der 21 15 1989 der zweite
tatzeitpunkt wo wir heute davon ausgehen
dass die zweite tötung dieses paares
stattgefunden hat war am 12 7 1989 alle
gegebenheiten vorher aber auch nachher
gerade im bereich der staatsforst gehört
können relevant sein
die polizei will wissen wer hat in
diesem zeitraum einen honda civic
gesehen der nach der tat in der göhrde
300 meter vom bahnhof in winsen luhe
gefunden wird
[Musik]
wer hat einen toyota telcel gesehen der
nach dem 2 doppelmord in der nähe der
diabetes klinik in bad bevensen
abgestellt wurde oder wer hat die fahrer
dieser fahrzeuge beobachtet
auf ihrer homepage sucht die polizei
lüneburg zudem nach zeugen oder
hinweisen zu den gegenständen und
kleidungsstücken die auf dem grundstück
von kurt werner bußmann befunden worden
und was den bezug angeht zu den
verstorbenen herrn wittmann sind uns
auch zeitzeugen wichtig die ihn kennen
die ihn begleitet haben die vielleicht
auch unserem umfeld gelitten
wenn sie hinweise haben oder
beobachtungen gemacht haben melden sie
sich bei der polizei lüneburg damit auch
die beiden doppel morde aus dem sommer
89 in der göhrde aufgeklärt und
vielleicht sogar mögliche weitere fälle
gelöst und mit täter dingfest gemacht
werden können
[Musik]